TO CHECK WITH YOUR BOSSES.
>> Bret: MIKE EMANUEL LIFE ON
THE HILL.
WE'LL BRING IN OUR PANEL TO DEAL
WITH THE NEWS OF THIS DAY, BYRON
YORK CHIEF POLITICAL
CORRESPONDENT OF THE
"WASHINGTON EXAMINER," JOSH
CRUSH, AND MATTHEW CONTINETTI
EDITOR IN CHIEF OF
"THE WASHINGTON FREE BEACON."
YOUR THOUGHTS, IT DOESN'T SEEM
LIKE THIS IS ANY DIFFERENT FROM
WHAT WAS ON THE TABLE A WHILE
AGO.
>> THIS SHUTDOWN WAS OVER A
BORDER BARRIER.
THE PRESIDENT DEMANDED CONGRESS
HAD TO GIVE HIM MONEY FOR THE
BARRIER OR ELSE HE WOULD KEEP
THE GOVERNMENT SHUT.
NOW HE HAS AGREED TO REOPEN THE
GOVERNMENT WITHOUT GETTING ANY
MONEY FOR THE BORDER BARRIER.
THE SHORT VERSION IS HELLO SEE
WON AND TRUMP LOST.
THE WHITE HOUSE AND ITS DEFENSE
SAYS THEY BELIEVE THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF DEMOCRATS ON
CAPITOL HILL THAT WOULD APPROVE
MONEY FOR A BORDER BARRIER AND
THAT'S RIGHT, THERE REALLY ARE
SUCH DEMOCRATS BUT THE
LEADERSHIP -- NANCY PELOSI HAS
NOT CHANGED, ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
FOR THE WALL POSITION.
SHE HAS NOT CHANGED HER POSITION
THAT WALLS ARE "IMMORAL," AND BY
NOT GIVING AN INCH, SHE HAS JUST
WON.
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHY THE
WHITE HOUSE THINGS AFTER WINNING
SHE WOULD START MAKING
CONCESSIONS.
>> Bret: I SAID NATIONAL
REVIEW, ITS NATIONAL JOURNAL,
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS DAY.
>> THE FIRST RULE OF GOVERNMENT
SHUTDOWNS AS YOU CAN NEVER HOLD
THE GOVERNMENT HOSTAGE AND
DEMOCRATS LEARNED THAT THE HARD
WAY WITH DACA, THEY TOOK THE
POLITICAL BLAME LAST YEAR FOR
TRYING TO HOLD THE GOVERNMENT
HOSTAGE.
REPUBLICANS ARE LEARNING IT
BECAUSE OF BORDER SECURITY.
NATIONAL POLLS ARE TOUGH FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE, 37% JOB APPROVAL,
IN OUR FOX POLL DEMOCRATS HAD A
TEN-POINT ADVANTAGE IN BORDER
SECURITY AND THAT HARDLY EVER
HAPPENS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP KNEW HE HAD TO
PUNT UNTIL THE POLITICS TURNED A
LITTLE BIT MORE FAVORABLY FOR
REPUBLICANS.
>> Bret: HERE ARE SENATE
LEADERS DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICAN.
>> DEMOCRATS ARE AGAINST THE
WALL BUT WE ACKNOWLEDGE WE NEED
TO IMPROVE STRENGTH AND SECURITY
IN THAT BODES WELL FOR COMING TO
AN EVENTUAL AGREEMENT.
>> THE DAYS AHEAD WILL TELL US
WHETHER OUR DEMOCRATIC
COLLEAGUES ARE SERIOUS ABOUT
SECURING OUR NATION, WHETHER
THEY MEAN WHAT THEY SAY.
>> Bret: THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER THE BASE, THE
PRESIDENT'S BASE IS REALLY
TURNED OFF BY THIS, THE PRESSURE
HAD GOTTEN TO A HIGH POINT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS TO WORRY
ABOUT HIS BASE AND THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY, THEY TURNED AGAINST
HIM ON THE SHUTDOWN THAT WAS
AGAINST THE WALL, MOST AMERICANS
ARE AGAINST THAT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS FIGHTING
AGAINST THE MOST POWERFUL FORCE
IN AMERICAN POLITICS -- IT'S NOT
NANCY PELOSI, IT'S PUBLIC
OPINION.
I THINK THE WHITE HOUSE SHOULD
LOOK AT THIS AS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BEGIN TO TURN THE SHIP AROUND
AND HEAD TOWARD REELECTION IN
2020.
THERE IS A DEAL TO BE MADE.
EVEN THOUGH CHUCK SCHUMER IS
ADAMANTLY AGAINST THE WALL,
NANCY PELOSI WAS VERY BIG ABOUT
WHAT MIGHT BE INCLUDED IN THIS
DEAL.
THERE IS THE OPPORTUNITY TO GET
THE FRESHMAN DEMOCRATS WHO CAME
TO WASHINGTON WITH THEIR VOTERS
EXPECT THEM TO SOLVE PROBLEMS TO
BACK SOME TYPE OF BARRIER.
IT MIGHT NOT BE THE WALL OF
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DREAMS BUT ALL
HE NEEDS IS A LITTLE BIT IN
ORDER TO POLICE HIS CONSTITUENTS
HEADING INTO REELECTION.
>> Bret: IS THE IMMEDIATE WIN
NANCY PELOSI'S?
IS THE POTENTIAL FOR LONG-TERM
WIN ON BORDER SECURITY?
>> IT'S POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE
PRESSURE OF THE GOVERNMENT BEING
SHUT DOWN, PERHAPS PEOPLE COULD
TAKE A MORE SOBER LOOK AT THE
PRESIDENT'S LAST PROPOSAL WHICH
IN ADDITION TO MONEY FOR BORDER
BARRIER WOULD INCLUDE ALL SORTS
OF THINGS THAT BOTH PARTIES
LIKES.
MORE TECHNOLOGY TO DETECT DRUGS,
MORE BEDS AT DETENTION CENTERS,
MORE IMMIGRATION JUDGES, ALL THE
SORTS OF THINGS THAT WERE PART
OF A PACKAGE THAT BOTH PARTIES
IN THE PAST PRIOR TO TRUMP WHAT
ACTUALLY SUPPORT AND THAT WOULD
INCLUDE A PHYSICAL BARRIER AT
THE BORDER, ALWAYS PART OF THAT.
PERHAPS IT'S POSSIBLE WHEN ALL
THE CRAZINESS OF THE SHUTDOWN IS
OVER, PEOPLE WILL TAKE ANOTHER
LOOK AT THAT PROPOSAL.
>> Bret: WE ARE HEARING FROM A
PRODUCER THAT IT'S TOO SOON TO
DO THE STATE OF THE UNION ON
TUESDAY, THEY ARE FLOATING
FEBRUARY 5TH.
HE WANTED TO DELIVER THE STATE
OF THE UNION ADDRESS IN THE
HOUSE CHAMBER WITH ALL THE POMP
AND CIRCUMSTANCE.
>> IT'S GOING TO BE HIS
OPPORTUNITY TO GET SOME
POLITICAL MOMENTUM BACK.
REPUBLICANS WIN THE IMMIGRATION
ARGUMENT WHEN IT'S BROADLY ABOUT
BORDER SECURITY, BUT WHEN HE GOT
CAUGHT UP IN THE WALL THAT
REALLY PUT HIM AND REPUBLICANS
IN CONGRESS INTO A CORNER AND
EVEN HE BACKED OFF FROM THAT, IT
WAS JUST FOR STEEL SLATS OR A
COMBINATION OF BORDER SECURITY
MEASURES.
HE NEEDS TO RESET HIS
IMMIGRATION AGENDA WITH THE
STATE OF THE UNION BUT HE HAS TO
THINK MORE BROADLY.
HE CAN'T BE SPEAKING TO THE 35%
BASE, HE HAS TO LOOK AT THE
BROAD MAJORITY OF THE COUNTRY
THAT DOES WANT SOLID BORDER
ENFORCEMENT.
>> Bret: IN THE MEANTIME,
DEMOCRATS ARE RELISHING THE FACT
THEY ARE TWEAKING THE PRESIDENT
WITH NANCY PELOSI SUGGESTING SHE
IS THE BIG WINNER HERE.
REPRESENTATIVE KAREN BASS
TWEETING OUT THAT SPEAKER PELOSI
SHOULD GIVE THE STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS SINCE SHE'S
OBVIOUSLY THE ONE RUNNING THE
COUNTRY.
>> KAREN BASS IS WRONG, THE
PRESIDENT IS STILL THE
PRESIDENT, HE HAS ALL THE POWERS
OF THE OFFICE, YOU LOOK AT SOME
OF THE THINGS HE'S DONE, FOREIGN
POLICY FOR EXAMPLE, YOU SEE THE
IMMENSE POWER OF THE PRESIDENCY.
NANCY PELOSI IS AN EXTREMELY
SAVVY LEGISLATOR, SHE KNEW SHE
HAD A WINNING HAND ESPECIALLY
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP IN DECEMBER
SAID HE WOULD TAKE THE CREDIT OR
BLAME IF THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOW
SHUTDOWN.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN THE
PUBLIC LISTEN TO PRESIDENT TRUMP
AND THEY BLAMED HIM.
NOW IT IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO TRY
TO NOT ONLY RESET THE
IMMIGRATION DEBATE BUT THINK
SERIOUSLY AND STRATEGICALLY